Wie ist die Lage?
Die Lage ist super. Wir haben sehr viel Spass und jetzt die Chance auf eine Welttournee, was wir schon immer machen wollten.
Wir koennen uns nicht beschweren.
Euer Leben hats sich in den letzten Monaten geaendert, oder?
Oh ja, es hat sich in den letzten Monaten veraendert. Wir koennen uns viel mehr auf die Musik konzentrieren. Vorher hatten einige von uns andere Berufe, teilweise zwei auf einmal.
und jetzt koennen wir uns einfach auf die Musik konzentrieren.
Was hast du vorher gearbeitet?
Ich habe Toiletten verkauft.
Hey, warum lachst du?
Das ist eine ganz andere Richtung.
Ich weiss, ich verkaufe auch keine mehr, aber es war ein sehr elegantes Geschaeft.
Ich war auf einer Musikschule und jetzt erlebe ich das alles sozusagen in echt. Das ist eine gute Veraenderung.
Ich war Trucker.
Ich habe Trucks gefahren, ja.
Ich habe Hunde ausgefuehrt.
Ja, ich mach das noch immer, ich liebe es. Ich liebe Hunde.
Es gibt kaum Vergleichbares.. einfach den Stress loswerden, indem man mit einem grožen alten Hund spazieren geht.
Aber dafuer hast du doch gar keine Zeit mehr, oder?
Nein, nicht wirklich, aber ich finde immer ein bisschen Zeit dafuer, wenn ich nach Hause komme.
Er sucht sich irgendwelche Hunde und geht mit ihnen. Er braucht das zum Entspannen.
Hast du einen Hund?
Ja!
Ich kann mit ihm gehen!
Aber es ist ein Malteser, ein sehr kleiner. Nach 500 Metern hat er genug fuer einen Tag.
Super, ich mach es fuer den halben Preis, wenn das so ist.
Was denkt ihr zu euer momentanen Situation? Was sind die Unterschiede, was hat sich geaendert?
Vieles hat sich geaendert. Wir verbringen mehr Zeit miteinander. Jede Sekunde des Tages - zusammen.
Wir koennen uns einfach auf die Musik konzentrieren, das ist alles, was wir je wollten.
Wie kann man bei so einer schnellen Karriere noch planen?
Ihr habt frčh angefangen, ja. Aber es ging jetzt sehr schnell bergauf.
Das kann man so nicht mehr planen.
Man muss dafuer bereit sein. Es hat natčrlich viel mit gutem Timing und Glčck zu tun, aber man muss auch erst alles dafčr aufbauen und dafčr bereit sein.
Als es losging haben wir ein richtiges Business daraus gemacht und uns ein Team besorgt. Die uebernehmen viele Entscheidungen. Das ist ganz gut so.
Wir werden das auch weiterhin so handhaben und hoffen, es funktioniert lange.
Mit dem Internet kann man wirklich grož werden. Du kannst die ganze Welt sehen und innerhalb von Minuten mit an Bord ziehen.
Und habt ihr diesen Erfolg Geplant?
Ja! Ja das haben wir.
Wir haben unser Leben lang darauf hingearbeitet und jetzt hat es endlich geklappt.
Wir sind sehr dankbar dafuer. Und ja! Wir haben es geplant! Definitiv.
Was sagen eure Familie und Freunde jetzt dazu?
Sie reden viel darueber und sind deswegen sehr gespannt.
Es gibt diese Sache in Kanada, die nennt sich "toldaso".
Das bedeutet sozusagen: Told you so!
Das ist es, was ich jetzt immer zu meinen Eltern gesagt habe, nachdem das passiert ist.
Was sind eure naechsten Plaene?
Habt ihr einen Plan?
Oder habt ihr jetzt eurer Ziel erreicht?
Nun ja, wir haben jetzt dieses tolle Team mit an Bord und arbeiten mit Culumbia. Unser Plan ist es, das beste Album aller Zeiten aufzunehmen, dazu auf Tour zu gehen und es dann wieder und wieder zu tun.
Und wir wollen den Kontakt zu unseren Fans durch Social Media halten. Facebook, YouTube..
Wir arbeiten wirklich hart, weshalb es "kick-ass" bleiben wird.
Ihr hattet jetzt viel Erfolg mit Coversongs. Wird euer Album nur Coversong beinhalten?
Nein, wird es nicht. Wir haben einige Originale und dazu gibt es dann ein paar Coversongs.
Wir werden aber auch nicht von Coversongs weggehen. Wir covern Songs nicht, um mehr Erfolg zu haben, sondern weil wir die Songs moegen und wir Musik lieben.
Also nehmen wir die Songs, aendern sie in einen WOTE-Style um und machen sie zu unseren Songs. Das macht man schon seit den 60-ern so.
Bob Dylan, Jimmy Hendrix, die haben alle dieselben Songs gespielt.
Wir werden damit weitermachen, aber haben ebenso viel Vertrauen in unsere eigenen Songs, die wir seit 6-7 Jahren machen.
Wir werden das auch auf jeden Fall beibehalten. Originale WOTE-Songs und Coversongs
Dann wčnsche ich euch noch viel Erfolg!